and and and now we learn the fbi the
aerial surveillance footage so you mean
the fbi was was surveilling the riots
from from with a drone
and they've not charged any of these
people
what the ever living
f or released the information to help
this court proceeding to help this trial
go along in a more accurate honest way
uh you know why hasn't that been
released so our taxes were used for that
money yeah so here's here's the thing
right that case is going down in state
court the fbi is a federal law
enforcement agency whose mandate is in
federal court now that doesn't mean that
the fbi doesn't participate in crimes
that are prosecuted in state court but
very very rarely and they the way they
view it is that's a separate court
system it's a wisconsin state court
system we do not have any obligation to
do anything we have no relationship with
that prosecutor to do anything and they
can hide behind that but why didn't they
bring any charges is it because it's not
a federal offense
they could but usually what would happen
is the doj would bring charges and they
would supersede any of these charges but
the problem is you have again a
politicized law enforcement community
where they're saying because of the
riots because of everything that
happened here
the number one target is kyle
rittenhouse so we can't go ahead and
supersede with the federal prosecution
for another defendant or possible
defendant because they want to see how
that case plays out because they don't
want to take the heat away from that did
you see that uh they had a subpoena for
the phone of gage gross kroitz the guy
with the gun and they didn't enforce it
they didn't enact it they ignored it and
the defense actually asked one of the
detectives is it normal that you'll get
a search warrant and not use it and he
was like well sometimes and he was like
did the prosecutors ask you
to
and you know use that search warrant and
he goes no he's like is it weird that
you've been granted the ability to
search the phone of this guy and you
said no to that
that's i mean to the so there's one
remedy for all this right
when the jury trial is over the judge
any judge has the authority to issue
contempt proceedings what that means is
you do not need a prosecution you do not
need a department of justice or state
attorney general's office the judge can
call any witness or the prosecutor that
appeared before him and said i think you
lied to me i'm holding you in contempt
of court it's a state felony you have
you have to bring an attorney and show
me why i shouldn't throw you in prison
and it happens rarely but in a case like
this where you're talking about all
these possibilities of exculpatory
evidence prosecutorial misconduct the
only person that can keep it straight as
a judge
it when watching this trial
the state is going fully motion
trying to get this this this gage gross
kirk's guide to like cry on the stand
almost he's like i thought i was going
to die the media fully complicit you
look at the media on this and it's
similar to the chauvin trial you'd think
the prosecution was like hitting slam
dunks this guy was like i was trying to
stop him and i thought i was going to
die but i had to and it's like you
actually listen to the testimony and
he's like i want 10 million dollars from
the city
and
but in state court that's the difference
between state and federal court right
the media is allowed in tv cameras are
allowed into state courtrooms tv cameras
are not allowed in a single federal
courtroom in the united states of
america which is why you get those
cartoon sketches you never get
videotaped never allowed but when you do
you play on it jack pasobic had a good
tweet i don't think he got every single
reporter that was down there but i'll
give a shout out we had what it was bg
on the scene it was richie mcginnis it
was julio rosas it was ford fisher who
else was down there
shelby shelby shelby talcott was down
there and then yeah was drew down there
hernandez no no he wasn't i don't
remember who does live's matter show is
that drew yeah that's true yeah he was
there oh yeah he was there yeah
all of these guys these reporters all
these people if they were not there
this would not be yeah i mean
rittenhouse would be locked up on the
emotional testimony alone but it is it
is
like i have personal experience with the
no cross prosecution thing
it's scary to me that we're at a point
where
during the criminal proceedings for kyle
rittenhouse determining whether or not
he was acting in self-defense we're
getting evidence of other crimes
committed by a ton of other people and
it's actually starting to sound like the
crimes were committed against kyle but
he's the one on trial it's scary and
there's
unfortunately no way to remedy it unless
this judge intervenes afterwards he's a
good judge though he seems to be pretty
good and he might he might look he's a
smart judge because you don't intervene
mid-trial that's the dumbest thing you
can do as a judge right you just hold
powder because you know there's things
you can do afterwards
if we get a directed verdict that'd be
nuts but the fear is there's gonna be a
riot yeah he and he's not gonna do it
yeah he's just not gonna he he you
cannot take the judge the case out of
the jury's hand as a judge you just
can't do that even even when it goes
this far like because he can always do
it after right
that's what i mean yeah afterwards
so one of the crazy things is that there
was uh uh
i can't remember exactly what the
prosecutors were asking of the witness
but it was objected by the defense on
habit and customs i think it's called
are you familiar with that yeah so he
was saying you know objection your honor
he's it's something related to habits
and customs can you explain what that
means yeah basically what happens is
when you have a witness on the witness
stand and you're trying to get facts
into evidence you need that witness to
testify to it sometimes what you can say
is oh
john q voter he woke up every morning at
9am picked up his glock went out to the
backyard and shot 17 rounds if you can
prove that he did that every day you can
allow that testimony to come in from a
witness who saw it based on habit and
custom that's what that's done
the defense objected on these grounds
and the judge said
he said sustained yeah and the defense
back-talked the judge
and the the i'm sorry not the defense
the prosecutor oh okay the prosecutor
was was was asking a question the
defense objected the judge sustained the
defense and so the prosecutor back
talked to the judge saying but this is
all habit and customs and the judge goes
you don't need to comment on my rulings
yeah dude
oh man i've been on the receiving end of
that in the giving end of that and it's
uh it's cool i was reading a legal
analysis from andrew branca and he was
like whoa you do not back talk the judge
like is going bad for them when it's
going downhill you you get out of the
way i mean this and the defense attorney
seems to be doing it the right way if
the judge is if the judge is going after
the prosecutor and ruling in your favor
you're just kind of like all right keep
going i'm i'm
every day
more and more shocked that this is even
happening that the trials even happening
should we make predictions what do you
guys think is going to happen
and i i was saying before life in prison
because
they're going to convict them on the
murder charges
my my view initially was that if just
based on what happened in the chauvin
trial there would be no political
willpower to defend principle the jurors
are going to say i don't want to be here
in the first place right the judge is
going to say i got a million to one
cases to deal with i don't need this one
and no one is gonna stick their neck out
for this kid
however the judge has been pretty fair
he's not given the defense everything
they've wanted
there's been a few rulings where he's
like you know no they tried getting uh
the gun charge i think thrown out yeah
because they say that the law
specifically says it doesn't apply to 16
and 17 year olds it's uh for those
aren't familiar the law says a minor
can't carry a weapon yeah but it
specifically says an exemption this is
what they argued 16 and 17 year olds are
exempt from this and the judge was like
that's for the jury to decide on the
charge right then they also tried saying
the reckless endangerment charge should
be should it should like i think they're
trying to get thrown out arguing that
richie mcginnis is the reason for the
reckless endangerment charge i think
it's reckless endangerment that when
written house was firing on rosenbaum
richie mcginnis was right there and he
created a reasonable harm to richie thus
there's the charge but they specifically
say in the law if you're acting in
self-defense you did not create a
reckless you know situation or whatever
and the judge said that'll be for the
jury to decide so he wasn't going to
give them exactly what they wanted but
there was an instance where the defense
accidentally referred to gross croix as
a victim
and the judge and he was like oh i'm
sorry the judge was like strike that
comment yeah they're not
what's at trial right now is whether or
not these people are victims so when i
started seeing how the judge was acting
when he said you can't call these people
victims but you can't call them rioters
i was like wow
like i'm actually impressed he's willing
to
stand up for this
the crazy thing i don't know if you saw
this was when he ragged on jeffrey
toobin it was that's his name right
jeffy too jeffrey
yeah yep yeah because
they were ragging on the judge
and the judge was like i have followed
this to the law who is the media to come
and start criticizing the work we're
doing they're undermining this court
proceeding and that's really really bad
so i see all that stuff and now my
prediction is probably
i think they'll get them on the gun
charge i think they're gonna they're
gonna get him on a mismeter gun charge
i'm not a lawyer so you're the lawyer so
actually
recovering recovering yeah but it sounds
like they'll get them on a manslaughter
thing out of fear yeah a version of
manslaughter maybe involuntary
manslaughter and something like that
some sort of some sort of act
that the jury can be like look we
convicted him now over to you judge for
sentencing so the judge can still give
him a stiff sentence or he could be like
here's 10 years of probation and i think
uh so far we're still only on the
state's case right it does the state
presents their case then the defense
which is a defense yeah and then the
state goes again it goes again so
i think we still have what like two
weeks or probably these cases go for a
while look the defense if they got
everything they want and i haven't been
following this case like you guys have
but i probably would not put on a case
if you get everything you want then you
remove the state's possibility of doing
a rebuttal case and just repeating their
entire prosecution and you just kind of
screw the prosecution if you get the
facts you want that you can argue in
closing if they acquit rittenhouse he
can't be tried again on unrelated
charges not in state court in federal
court he could
but even if it's like a different charge
what if they're like okay now we're
going to try and charge him for
something
different but from the event so there's
a whole like legal equation that goes
into that it's really hard to beat i
mean they'd have to be like a totally
different series of events we didn't
know about it before new witnesses new
evidence new timeline so i'm not gonna
honestly he gets acquitted he gets
acquitted he gets acquainted but if he
gets convicted he appeals oh yeah
well what do you guys think
the evidence is looks like it's
defense like he defended himself the
dude was pulling a gun and coming at him
i mean that guy the first guy said if i
get you alone i'll effing kill you yikes
it's the that i can't
and these are the state's witnesses it's
a state's case that's what i mean it's
like the conversation of if i put myself
in a bear cage and then the bears attack
me and i kill the bears i was defending
myself but i also put myself in the
position where those bears had to die
well hold on but let's let's let's let's
fix the analogy what if
it's not you're putting yourself in a
bear cage it's that you have a
gigantic silo full of honey and a bear
has shown i have to protect the honey
and so you're like hey this is my honey
get away from me and the bear tries to
kill me i've been eating a lot of honey
and
and the bear says if i get you alone
i'll effing kill you then i'm on guard
yeah so it isn't the same as just
entering a bear cage and being like oh
no it's coming right forward and he was
there to protect the the gas station and
the buildings and stuff yeah what are
your thoughts on that let's say it was a
stupid thing to do to think he was going
to be protecting that
i mean
probably not the smartest thing to do
but it's whether or not he has the legal
ability to do it so it doesn't it
doesn't affect self-defense right it it
can depending on the circumstances whose
property it is who you you can step in
to defend
anyone if you feel objectively their
life is being in danger self-defense
applies to the person property is a
little different if it's someone else's
property you're probably not going to
get away with the self-defense argument
it's your property that you own well
apparently apparently the owners of the
car place or whatever said we didn't ask
for their protection
so that's uh yeah that's but not a good
fact for them i i think anybody who's
going to come out and say it's it's like
um there's the state has nothing would
be wrong you know and and i'll say like
i've been hyperback on instagram i'm
like it's over and it's like but i don't
mean to say because i i mentioned this
in my my main video the state does have
some things right the guy gage gross
kroitz testified that
the only reason rittenhouse didn't shoot
him while his hands were up was that he
missed the gun misfired and so what he
said was written house was pointing the
gun at him while he had his hands up and
then rittenhouse pulled this the pulled
the uh the rail the rack yeah the rail
back to clear and then re-chamber to
chamber around and the media is
reporting it as kyle rittenhouse held
him at gunpoint while he reloaded the
gun which is like not what he said but
the argument is from the witness this is
what the jury heard that rittenhouse
pulled the trigger and the gun misfired
so then he pulled the rack back to
re-chamber around and then fired on
gauge gross crates so it's not
like the state has nothing no they got
stuff to work with right i mean you're
talking about reloading a firearm that
you already pointed at the target not
reloading but i know but that's what the
right that's what they're even if i was
a prosecutor in that case that's kind of
how i would describe it because you can
kind of get away with the facts saying
it's a reload and you you want the jury
to hear reload instead of the correct
terminology i want to make sure i'm
being fair you know because the state
does have their their offense but i will
also point out the defense rebutted by
showing there was another man who had
his hands up that reynolds also didn't
fire upon oh so if the argument from
you know gage was that he did but my
hands were up and it's like well how do
you explain the other guy with his hands
up he didn't fire on either of you so
it's like you can't claim that he was
just singling you out
so
i guess we'll see how that plays out huh
we'll see what we'll see what happens as
the the case progresses gage is the guy
that got his bicep blown yeah vaporized
cheese
but this this dude was lying the whole
time it was nuts
guys attacked him one guy came at him
with a skateboard like he was going to
smash him over the head he did smash him
over the head and they showed video of
it and they even asked the detective
where's the skateboard and he was like
oh i don't know it's like isn't that
important to have and it's like we
didn't look for it they asked like did
you do a swab for dna on the rifle to
see if rosenbaum had grabbed it and he's
like no
why wouldn't do any of those things and
another thing the defense brought up is
he's like you filed charges against
written house before the investigation
was completed and they're like yes
and he's like so you didn't have the
full facts of the case before you file
charge and he goes yeah but that's
that's typical that's usually what
happens in state court so it's
difference between state court and
federal court state court you charge the
defendant and then you build your case
right federal court you build your case
then you charge your defendant and i
think it's fair to point out too the
detective said we have a high profile
homicide where people you know see video
of it so charges are laid and then we
start putting together the investigation
but i think it's obvious to anybody
who's being honest that they overcharged
oh yeah
calling it a homicide
seems they got to prove that they can't
just say it's homicide just means a
person killed a person yeah that's not i
see it doesn't mean you intentionally
murdered somebody that's what people
don't understand activists don't get
this they'll be like you know a guy was
killed by a cop they ruled it a homicide
and they'll go whoa that proves it like
it just means someone died someone died
as a result of human action i believe
right so a homicide may not be illegal
homicide's never illegal it's just
interesting you're dead circumstances
yeah yeah it mean what does it mean
specifically it means person killed
person yeah yeah yeah and then
accidental death you know the suicide
means person killed self and regicide
means person killed king also known as
a man slayer
that is the word i'm pretty sure it's
wretched or it is registered yeah tyrion
yeah yeah
i love it you have patricide mattress
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you